there's so much happening in the world
of britney spears and the pop icons
fight to end her conservatorship
here's the latest on tuesday brittany
took to instagram with new comments
about the ongoing legal battle
leaving her thoughts next to this image
that spells out one day at a time
am i ready to take the stage again am i
going to take the stage again will i
ever take the stage again
i have no idea britney says despite a
previous message she shared that read
life goes on she now believes that's
easier said than done and says
i think we all know that i will never be
able to let go and fully move on
until i've said all i needed to say she
added
i was told to stay quiet about things
for so long and i finally feel like i'm
just getting here
i once again want to thank britney
spears for her courage
and for her strength i want to thank
judge penny
for her courtesy in welcoming my firm
and i into this case
britney's comments come a day after this
statement from her new attorney matthew
rosegaard
and i also want to thank britney spears
fans and supporters
outreach and support from my firm myself
and most importantly britney has truly
been overwhelming
from coast to coast and literally
throughout the world while addressing
reporters outside of the los angeles
county courthouse on monday
he said they're moving aggressively to
remove her father
jamie spears from the conservatorship
finally
and the last thing i'm going to say
about this matter
is as i said in court last week
and outside my firm and i are moving
aggressively and expeditiously
to file a petition to remove jamie
spears
unless he resigns first thank you amid
this tense situation
britney has made a point to highlight
some joyful moments in her life
that i was proud of really on sunday
boyfriend sam asgary shared this special
car ride to his instagram story
where britney sang along to her 2001
album track
lonely
[Music]
then yesterday britney showed off some
gifts from a high profile supporter
[Music]
while she's a go-to on britney's workout
playlist selena gomez also makes some of
her favorite cosmetics
britney posted this photo to instagram
and explained when i woke up i got a
very cool box with a bikini in it
and my favorite three makeup products
from selena gomez
selena replied this makes me so happy i
hope you enjoy it
love you so much she finally has an
advocate now
that not only is qualified but is
someone that
she picked out so what's next for
britney's legal battle
president of the law and crime network
rachel stockman spoke with e.t last week
she said the addition of a new attorney
for brittany will prove to be a game
changer
matthew rosengard is a great addition to
her team
he's very well respected he's a real
fighter
and i think she really does have a real
chance of winning this now
it's a really interesting question about
whether or not there'll be an
investigation into her father and into
her claims
the question here is there a legal claim
is there a criminal claim
we don't know all of the details yet and
if there is an investigation
a lot more could be revealed i do
think more information needs to come out
and i do think it would probably be
worthy of an investigation
of some sort